j hat has done a nice job settling into
the
rotation here see the real state of
pitching location location location
so with the doley's garcia coming up
this one lined out to right field
that'll get down for a base hit
kinder philippa around third base he
scores easily
so garcia with an rbi single gets the
scoring started for the rangers in the
first inning
one nothing yeah high and deep to center
field boxton back
and the wall makes the catch
gallow just missed making it a
four-nothing game
i don't know if the wind is not this
fall down there all off left-handed
hitters bound this ball slicing just a
little bit towards
left center field so kyle gibson on
tonight for the rangers making the start
against his hometown team in the
organization that he came up with this
will be the seventh start of the season
but it has been a very nice season so
far
so one on one out twins down one and
here comes byron buxton 1-0 pitch a
swing of the drive left center field and
deep
back it goes deep it goes and go on a
home run
to the bullpen in left center field
byron buxton
one swing twins are on top two to one
of this at the high fastball and that
strikeout ends the inning
but the twins get the run back and then
some byron buxton's two run homer has
him in front two to one
two two and this one on the ground and
into left field that's a base hit for
solac
nick is on to start things here in the
third inning
here's the one two there's a swing and a
miss
he gets donaldson his third strikeout
there's a swing and a miss and buxton
strikes down into one two three for kyle
gibson
to the right field corner and down for a
hit
darver will be held to a single with
dahl getting to the ball in the corner
and lining a single into the right field
corner with two out in the fourth
twins league two to one austin deal will
lead on playing first base tonight
the ball line to left hit well calhoun
going back that ball is gone a home run
ostadillo's third of the year
kyle gibson came into the game with no
home runs allowed and the twins
have taken him deep twice the twins now
lead three to one
chopper by the mound towards short bare
hand kind of for leftover long time and
he gets simmons
great defensive play by isaiah for out
number one
fantastic play and this was slowly
developing and i'm thinking about
what is isaiah kind of left the thinking
about as he's getting to this baseball
right he's got to figure out
can i go to the glove no i better go
bare hand with simmons running and even
though it wasn't close
i think if simmons was going full speed
it might have been a little bit closer
he looked like he's starting to pull up
a little bit early but
it doesn't matter great job to see the
wide grip there from isaiah
has a chance to get the lefty here
strike three boy delayed call
by the home plate umpire but half have
been payton right there got strike one
strike two
and went back out there it's a good
pitch
that ball and sharply up the middle base
hit
so the right-hander garcia gets him for
a second time tonight
now two more lefties coming up meanwhile
looks like we might have a pitching
change
and j hap again giving the twins a
really good chance to win going five in
the third innings
and he might pick up his third straight
win here tonight
happ's going to get a nice hand as he
departs here with one on one out
twins up three to one
let's hit to the left center field gap
and buxton dives and makes another
tremendous catch
don't hit it there he'll catch it
was that a couple years ago nothing
falls but raindrops
it's amazing to watch him go after a
ball close ground
you can see i wouldn't say he timed his
jump right here but figured out exactly
when he needed to leave his feet
with a left-handed hitter that ball is
going to be tailing away from him
understanding that
doing a nice job of going to get it and
for doll guy who's hitting
now 200 on the year it seems like you
hit it hard and that ball uh
you hear the mvp chance start up again
but
he's going come on i need that one i'm
not hitting 400 like you are
you gotta let one of those fall
in the air left side foul ground
culverson is there that a boy
almost overran gibson into the wind and
lets it fly
got him looking on a high fastball one
two three inning for kyle gibson his
seventh strikeout of the night
he finishes off strong here he has
retired 12 batters in a row since the
estadio home run
in the fifth 2-0 pitch
and calhoun hammers his ball high in the
air deep out to ride
it's gone willie calhoun goes yard
and it's a one-run game look out but
could the rangers
do it again tonight and this one rolled
slowly to third base donaldson bobbled
[Applause]
and culverson is on a rare misplay
by josh donaldson down at third base and
the rangers have that tying run on in
the ninth
this one rolled through short and into
left field base hit
and abanez has his first major league
yet he's moved the tying run
into scoring position that is awesome
what a great moment for him
i mean first of all you're gonna forget
this one right first big league
appearance first big league hit all of
it but
doing it in the middle of a ninth inning
rally here for the texas rangers
now first pitch swinging and this one
lofted into short
center field that's a tough play and
edelton simmons got to it
tagging it third gulberson scores and we
are tied at three
well that was a tough play either way
for the twins
you have a better shot if buxton gets it
coming in from center
but simmons made the play and the
rangers have tied it i love the reaction
of isaiah kind of left with the dugout
and then brings up
adolesce garcia paul lifted high in the
air
deep out to left cave is back at the
wall
gone just got over
a two run shot for adolesce garcia
whose mastery of the road continues and
the rangers lead 5-3
culverson hits this ball hard down into
the left-field corner that'll get
another run
home gallows scores culverson
cruises to second with the rbi double
and it's a 6-3 rangers lead
yeah you feel pretty good about ian
kennedy being the guy
to close the door in the ninth inning
and this one rolled shortstop could be
two there's
one out at second the throw onto first
and time double play
by the rangers came storming back to
tide in the ninth
they win it an extras six three the
final score
to even the series it'll win a piece